こんにちははじめ社長です
新入生新入社員のみなさん
新生活
おめでとうございます
[音楽]
ん
re
大丈夫ですか twitter うちのほなくるんですけども
新しい生活が始まり新しい学校が始まり
新しく会社が始まり心細いです
一人ぼっちです
どうしようっていう人
たくさんいいと思います
[音楽]
こそもその一人でした
僕の地元は富山県富山県出身で高校が大学に移動するときに
静岡大学に行くために富山県を離れて静岡大学に行きました
俺の周りでは
誰一人
静岡県に行く人はいませんでした大学の中でも富山県の先輩もいない
どうか懸念の人は一人もいない
僕は
登録02の状況デー
大学行ったんです
[音楽]
正直に話します大学の入学式まで
一心に週間からやったと思うんですけど
ベッドで
一人で泣いてました
家族もいないし
友達もいない
一緒にご飯を食べる人もいない
[音楽]
外に忘れない人ばっかり
頼れる人も1人もいない
[音楽]
だから俺は
よくわかる新生活が始まって会社に
頭立て知り合いが一人もいない
新しい学校に友達知り合いが一人もいない
そんな人絶対いると思います
あーわかるよ
俺ならわかる
[音楽]
とっても心細いよな
あーわかるよ痛いほど分かる
どうなっちゃうんだろスタートダッシュが伸び遅れれば友達02のまま生活が始まって
しまう
そんなも最悪ならー
[音楽]
怖いよ
誰だって怖いよ
俺も強かった俺はパッと見よおきゃっぽい見た目をしてるけど結構感じでコミュ障で
自分から人に話しかけに行くことができないんだ
そんな僕でも
なんとか
友達ができました何年か友達ができて
気づいたらたくさん友達ができて
サークルに入ったんですけど
上言い k surf デー
ノリについていけず
途中で
やめだかもあったでもそんな過去があるからこそ
かんだでもそんな過去があるからこそ
今のユーチューバー肇社長があると思っています
ひとりぼっちの君へ
無理して友だちや知り合いが作らなきゃって思ったら余計焦っちゃうからあんまり
ガツガツ行かない方がいいと思う
これは
インキャからの言葉だ
大丈夫
必ず自分と気が合う友達知り合いが絶対できる
彼に気がはないと思ってさができたとしても自然と
関係はなくなっていくでしょう僕みたいに自分で言うのもなんだけど
俺はこの静岡県で
友達知り合い先輩後輩
誰一人
誰一人と思う
ci お友達もいない完全に一人だけの状況から
友達や後輩がある程度できるところまでも仕上がってきました
大丈夫
コミュ力がなくても
君なら
できる自分を信じて
よ頭がしすぎずかといって挽きすぎず
ありのままの自分でいてみてください
ジャミン大学の友達はたくさんできたんですけど今連絡をとれるのは1人か2人です
ひとりぼっちで何もなかった大学生活だったからこそ言える
僕からの新生活を送る
ひとりぼっちの一例の
応援メッセつです
ジャグラー a
[音楽]